[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so anyway, you return to the palace and basically you make sure that the guards put the prisoners in your guard house.
[SPEAKER_00]: How do you want to separate these?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want them all separated from each other.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, everybody has their own self.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there any particular kind of cell that you want to put the two major ones in?
[SPEAKER_00]: The best cell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so the biggest, the smallest, the most horrible, what is the best?
[SPEAKER_01]: Choices.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, let's get like a horrible white light with the brrrr noise.
[SPEAKER_01]: Comfy walls, nothing to kill themselves with.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fairly sized.
[SPEAKER_00]: So fairly sized, but secure.
[SPEAKER_00]: The most secure, you put those two and the two most secure cells that are.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: As the prisoners are put away, you notice that the six that your men picked up off the floor of the front room are pretty much non-responsive and don't even seem like they realize they're awake.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're pretty much in a dream.
[SPEAKER_00]: Whereas the other two are...
[SPEAKER_00]: They have to be hooded because they're trying to bite people and are very, very angry and violent.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're drunk down.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're crazy.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's something insane about them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: Around midnight, you have them all secure, and the guards have finished securing the area, and most people have returned to their place.
[SPEAKER_00]: How many people do you want to stay here, of the guard, to watch them this evening?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are they the Marines, or is it... No, the Marines basically transfer them up to where you are.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Marines went back down to the harbor district.
[SPEAKER_01]: And these are just royal guards, I'm assuming?
[SPEAKER_01]: Palace guards, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mostly just want the Scarlet Brotherhood to have the most secure.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many guards do you want to allocate to it?
[SPEAKER_01]: How much is usually done?
[SPEAKER_00]: Normally there'd be one man watching two prisoners behind bars.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's up that to probably five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you want five guys with weapons.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Watch these guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: That seems fair.
[SPEAKER_00]: Keep your crossbows on them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they look at you funny, just go ahead and... Alright, so it's pretty late.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where do you want to go?
[SPEAKER_01]: Um...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd like to find out now where Jude is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what do you do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Um...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm pretty sure the reason I even came back here was because I figured that Jude would probably come here or be here unless something else is happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna stay put.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to send a message to the front gate to basically say if Jude shows up, bring him to me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: That'd be good.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you send a runner down to the north gate to basically look for Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to stay up waiting for him in your bedroom?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'll stay down in the dungeon and I'd like to question the six methed out
[SPEAKER_00]: So you spend an hour basically trying to get these people to talk to you and their babbling is incoherent and you begin to realize that there's very little that you're going to learn from them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not only do they look very, very malnourished and out of it, but it's almost as if
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, it's as if they're dreaming.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your guards try to wake them, they slap them.
[SPEAKER_00]: How invasive do you want to get?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, as invasive as I can be.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to burn them?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not hurt or hurt them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Slap and water on the face.
[SPEAKER_00]: Water on the face?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_00]: Very much unresponsive to your activity, except at one point one of the guys looks at you and goes, the dragon, the dragon, and falls asleep again.
[SPEAKER_01]: The dragon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, let's start with them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's catch and release.
[SPEAKER_00]: You tell your guys you want them to leave?
[SPEAKER_00]: I just get them out of here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Waste of space.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where should we put them, sir?
[SPEAKER_00]: Where we found them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Back in the Warren?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or you can just drop them off at the front north gate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just get them out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: The other two, though, you want to leave for later.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I gotta cook something up for them.
[SPEAKER_01]: I gotta...
[SPEAKER_00]: So you go... Do you want to go back to your study where you and Jude talked originally and kind of contemplate things?
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait for Jude, or do you want to talk to these guys first?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, let's go ahead and...
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to go to the library.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to find a book about torture.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'd like to read that.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, there is a book about torture.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's actually probably down there in the dungeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: How to torture.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am sure the jailer knows, but he needs to know.
[SPEAKER_00]: You however want to study.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or it's like an old dusty book, A Noob's Guide.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: What, dummies?
[SPEAKER_00]: Torture for dummies.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so anyway, you're reading this book about torture when a knock comes onto the door and the servant looks into the room and says, Master Paul,
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude is here.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's been led in through the front gates.
[SPEAKER_00]: He wishes to talk to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, get him, please.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, we'll bring him right here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Am I in the library or are you there?
[SPEAKER_00]: The study.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which is kind of a library.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: It has a library.